if you were to ask somebody okay I have
whatever 50 embryos in the dish and what
I'm going to do is instead put 300
embryos in the dish what do you think is
going to happen to their health
typically the expectation would be it
should get worse because by by having
more embryos together you have more
opportunity for crowding effects for you
know toxic byproducts to accumulate for
you know oxygen to be um pulled out of
the medium and all that kind of stuff so
you would typically you you wouldn't
just not expect this effect you would
actually expect it backwards you would
expect to do worse in the larger group
and this is that that's why this is so
remarkable you know this is this is
really just completely counter counter
expectation